all right a week you try to call an
election and failed we lost four out of
four votes in the House of Commons you
see all your majority reduced from 1 to
minus 45 you see number Rudd Lee if you
seen Boris Johnson's brother leave I
mean how would you sum up how this
week's gone for you well it's obviously
been a rough week but the reality is the
Prime Minister is sticking to his guns
and what he said to get us out of this
rut that we're in we're going to keep
going on with the negotiations of the EU
we want to deal by the end of October
but we must leave come what may I think
the country otherwise will be drawn
quicker into the quicksand if you like
that's what Labour's surrend a bill that
Jeremy called him back this week would
mean we've got to get out of that rut
and one of the reasons we ought to get
out of the rut is talk about all the
positive things we do also have a
spending review this week we didn't
mention that where we talked about extra
police on the street leveling up school
funding as grappling with the social
care challenge all the things I think
most people if they voted leave or may
now want us to get focused on and not
keep talking Matt brexit get that done
keep our promises talk about those other
things too that's what the prime
minister's doing the challenge of course
is now to get break that down of course
because things that have perhaps got
slightly more complicated shall we say
what that's concerned I want to address
first the resignation of alvarado yes it
happened overnight she had some pretty
steering Christa's and did she of the
the party and didn't just resigned from
the cabinet but she also resigned from
the conservative whip
I mean what does it say about the state
to the conservative party when people
are amber Robb just can't stomach it
anymore longer I'm really sorry to see
and a step down I like her respect her
we became and bees at the same time in
2010 but I think in fairness when she
took the cabinet role everyone was asked
do you accept and can you sign up to him
will you support the Prime Minister's
plan to leave by the end of October
preferably with the deal but if not come
what may and we all accepted that and I
think the Prime Minister was right to
restore some discipline I think he's
right to expect it from his top team you
say that it was right to install some
discipline but is this now becoming a
party for brexit purists I mean you
effectively now the brexit party no I
guess I'd say in relation to first of
all what we've seen this week on the
nation vision more police on the street
grappling with school funding making
sure the NHS the investment gets to the
front line that shows you we want to
actually start talking about all the
things the bread-and-butter issues if
you like voters really care about
there's nothing that's changed since in
fairness and with respect since amber
took the cabinet role she was all she
thinks that the thing that's changed is
that it's no she doesn't believe that
the objective is there to get a deal
well I can tell you having been in all
of the subcommittee meetings and having
been out to talk to you foreign
ministers last week and if you look at
the change which is a question people
rightly asking what's changed in the
negotiations actually the EU have gone
from saying we can't touch the
withdrawal agreement or reopen it to
saying they're willing in principle to
do so that was a victory for the prime
minister at the g7 and we've been
following up on that so actually there
has been that progress but the one thing
holding us back is this sense in
Brussels that perhaps Parliament through
this surrender bill Jeremy Corbyn has
led would actually perhaps delay again
or even cancel brexit we can't have that
the other end immensely weakens our
negotiating position which is why with
respect I think the rebels this week
were wrong
well let's talk about the rebel showing
because this is another reason that
amber Rudd said she just could not stand
by we can have a quick look at something
she wrote in her resignation letter I
must also address the assault on decency
and democracy that took place last week
when you sacked 21 talented loyal One
Nation conservatives and she goes on to
say after that the short-sighted culling
of my colleagues has stripped the party
of broad-minded and dedicated
conservator and peas I cannot support
this act of political under listen she
says she can't stand by can you stand by
of course look the reality is and I
regret anyone's had whipped withdrawal
and I don't no one wants to see that
let's be clear about it this was because
they voted for motions and legislation
that gave Jeremy Corbyn control hold it
was important people I'm saying control
of the business of the House of Commons
and control of the negotiations they
were told in advance it would be a
confidence issue so I regret it but it
was their choice and they did it knowing
what the implications would be first and
foremost for the country that's the real
vandalism to democracy that's going on
and second of all in terms of the whip
being withdrawn so I regret it and we
need to keep the family together but the
- was very clear one of the reasons with
voters that we've seen an increase in
support for the Conservatives I think
it's given a clear sense of direction
and now we're going to stick to the plan
at the same time though you kicked out
former Chancellor's people like Ken
Clark who became an MP when Boris
Johnson was five years old people like
Philip Hammond who until six weeks ago
before he was kicked out was the
Chancellor people like David Gork it was
the first time he's ever broken the whip
I mean how many times have you ever
broken the concert to wit but not only
an issue of confidence and I've missing
David Cole no but I've never voted to
give you how voted on some big issues
Sophie let me answer the question I have
never voted to give Jeremy Corbyn
control of the legislature gender in the
House of Commons or control over the
brexit negotiations these are all decent
people I like them I respect them but it
was right the the discipline was
restored because they knew what they
were doing and I think the one thing
we've got some you you said that they
were you know you refer to status I
don't think your status in the party is
the key issue the question is whether
will you keep to your promises and you
understand our promises we all made at
the 2017 election our manifesto you
understand when you go into a vote like
that
it was very clear how serious this was
giving Jeremy called in that control
over the House of Commons over the
brexit negotiations they did what they
did knowingly and I think Boris Johnson
was right and I say this wheel
sorry not in anger to follow through on
that do you think I should be offered a
way back I think we always want to keep
building bridges and to make sure that
there are ways to keep their family
together but I think it's very difficult
having not just once but on a number of
occasions now voted on that those
confidence issues with the implications
that they've had making it so much
harder for us to get the deal with the
EU that everyone in the Conservative
Party wants I think they've made that
very difficult but that was a choice
that they made knowingly and aware all
the consequences and the implications
it's Dominic Cummings remember the
concept of policy I don't know you'd
have to ask him there I don't know I've
never had the conversation with you he
doesn't do interviews no well you know
advisers advise ministers decide but
actually the key thing with all of this
is that the people and this is I think a
big change that we've got ministerial
accountability we didn't have that in
fairness my experience of brexit with
all you
Vin's with the greatest respect to the
civil servants and I think we do have
that now so I think it's right that
elected politicians take responsibility
like I'm doing on the show with you do
you think that it's a bit strange you
don't know if he's a member or not
no there's loads of people that I don't
ask those sorts of questions of not
later provides in the moment to say
perhaps well I didn't have that
configure I've never had that
conversation with anyone that Vice Prime
Minister
actually we've there's a story about
Jang man who's Labour MP but helping us
with and some of the stuff that the
position this was an appointment under
Teresa may originally in relation to
anti-semitism well he's obviously not a
conservative we want to be a broad
Church actually conservative parties at
its best when we're a big tent broad
Church and we do need to keep the family
together and I and I want to see that
happen
but I do also think that on some of
these key issues people need to
understand and the voters get it that
we've got to keep to the plan and stick
the plan and we can't delegate any of
this stuff to Jeremy Corbyn it's too
dangerous let's let's talk about the
plan then because I'm really keen to try
and work out what the plan actually is
and just to with disgust and Burroughs
resignation literally I just want to
have a look at what she said in her
resignation letter when it comes to the
deal because she said one of the main
reasons for quitting is I no longer
believe that leaving with a deal is the
government's main objective the
government is expending a lot of energy
to prepare for no deal but I have not
seen the same level of intensity go into
our talks with the European Union who
have asked us to present alternative
arrangements to the Irish backstop I
mean lots of people will read that and
will be worried well first of all it's
not correct firstly because we have had
intense negotiations David Frost the
political appointment but the special
advisor to Prime Minister Steve Barclays
B now I've been out to Helsinki to speak
to you foreign ministers I've seen a
whole range of them to talk about brexit
but also all the other issues we're
working on but also one point about the
no deal planning of course that is
crucial to getting a deal because it
sends the message to Brussels that we
want to deal we've set that out but also
that we're going to leave at the end of
October if they continue to play
hardball so those two things are
actually linked and the big frustration
I've got this week is MPs that have
tried to take no deal off the table
explained that they
want an extension that sins that you the
wrong message at the wrong time I mean
the main thing stopping a deal though is
the fact that you want to get rid of the
backdrop that the EU says you have to
come up with alternative proposals have
you actually come up with some different
plans they're clearly whole range of
possibilities we've got the Prime
Minister's letter which sets out the
framework for it and David Frost and
Steve barky have been working through
the detail what are what have you
actually put forward anything so we've
been engaged in discussions what we
slightly reticent about doing given past
experience is putting pieces of paper
that will get leaked and rubbished by
the other side but the proposals will be
around things like intelligence-led
checks away from the border exemptions
for small businesses trusted trade
routes making sure that we can look at
maintaining the island of ireland and
not have any infrastructure the border
one of those conversations have been
ongoing and actually there's a really
credible way to sort this problem out
but it does require political will in
Dublin and from the rest of the EU we'll
continue with these negotiations the
Prime Minister's seeing the Irish tea
shock early next week and we are
committed absolutely to getting a deal
but one of the things that's crucial is
that no deal isn't taken off the table
first of all it's the responsible thing
to plan for and but secondly because it
gives the EU that crucial message that
we're serious about leaving and they
need to move to okay well let's try and
work out what happens if you can't get a
deal
sure if you take you at your word they
like it still your main objective but
what happens if it doesn't happen by the
deadline do you accept that the
legislation passed by Parliament the law
passed by Parliament compels Boris
Johnson to ask for an extension rather
than seeking No Deal if you can't get a
deal
well first of all the key thing with an
extension is it requires agreement on
both sides I think it's very difficult
for the legislation to micromanage in
detail how that conversation will go we
will adhere to the law but we'll also
because this is such a bad piece of
legislation the the surrender bill that
Jeremy Corbyn back we also want to test
to the limit what it does actually
lawfully require well that's the reason
then what does that mean look very
carefully at the implications and our
interpretation of it to make sure what
do you mean no I mean I mean actually
across the board we will look very
carefully legally at what it requires
and what it doesn't require
I think that's not only the lawful thing
to do it's also the responsible thing to
do and again I'll repeat that
legislation is lousy it envisages
multiple delays it would effectively try
and force us to accept conditions from
the EU however vindictive punitive or
harsh they may be and that's we if we
ended up extending we probably must make
clear he will not do it it would cost
the UK taxpayer gross figure a billion
pounds each month how the legislation of
the Congress will not extend in any
circumstances is that what you're saying
he's been very clear about it this week
so in that way in that he would either
ignore the legislation put forward we're
always going to behave nor Faliszek
government of course you'd expect that
and anyway it will be challenged in the
courts but we are going to do with that
legislation is test very carefully what
it does and doesn't require and that's
not only the lawful thing to do I think
it's the responsible thing to do the
irresponsible thing to do is to support
that legislation which weakens our
negotiating position in Brussels are you
prepared to take it to the courts to
test it if that's what it takes we can't
necessarily control that the people of
various points challenged the government
over brexit we had two legal challenges
last week alone but we won both of those
but these things just just think we're
effectively saying that you are prepared
to ignore this law that's been passed
and take and then be challenged on it in
the course as you know so yeah that's
not what I said what I said is we're
going to look at it very carefully test
what it legally requires and what it
doesn't require and that's the
responsible thing to do because it's
such a bad piece of legislation and I
think it was deeply responsible that
jeremy corbyn's put his weight behind it
he's trying to drag this country into
the quicksand deeper in deeper ways what
Boise Johnson is trying to do is get us
out of the bricks it right and get the
country moving forward I mean some
people will look at this and think this
is an example of Boris Johnson
effectively thinking that the rules
apply to everyone else and he doesn't
have to play by the rules no I don't
think that's true at all
what you're seeing is a prime minister
that's made a series of very clear
promises did get out of that you
preferably with a deal to talk about all
the other issues like policing schools
social care and sticking to his word I
think of anything
people are bit surprised that he's
sticking to his guns he's keeping his
word I mean that's what the voters
expect I'm saying that he would even go
to even go to prison if he ignores this
legislation this is ridiculous Sammy
of course it's not going to break the
law and of course I think these are all
politically motivated comments but the
reality is you see from some of the
polling that we've seen out just today
with the Sunday Times and elsewhere
actually the voters recognized that
we've got a prime minister that's trying
to get us out of the rut and you've got
Jeremy Corbyn who's got the handbrake on
breaks it and is not allowing the
country to move forward probably have
they even if it goes down well with the
public you've got to get to the election
fast and you've been blocked from doing
that and what a terrible look it is for
Jeremy Corbyn never in history have I
ever known a leader of an opposition
refuse to go to the polls to let the
voters decide it shows he doesn't trust
the voters and it doesn't say a lot
about his confidence in his own ability
to win that election and I'm afraid that
every Labour MP again on Monday when
we're gonna have another vote on this
he's going to have to day-by-day explain
that to their voters why they're not
allowing the country to move forward and
then not allowing us to resolve this
with an election if it does happen
Monday you're gonna try again we're
going to keep with the plan which is to
get a deal by the end of October and if
not to leave on WTO terms and if we
can't get that through of course we're
going to as a matter of necessity not
because we want to go to the country to
get there backing in the mandate for it
just wanna have a quick look at
something that Boris Johnson said during
the leadership campaign this is in july
2019 i think the people of this country
are utterly fed up with politicians
coming back to them with more elections
it's totally wrong do you ever wonder
why on earth people have such little
trust in politicians when they say one
thing and then a couple months later
they're doing exactly the opposite look
the reality is we don't want an election
but it's being forced on us it was being
forced on this by because we don't have
control over the numbers in parliament
when that happens everyone forced on you
you're trying to make it happen no it's
been forced on us because we have so
limited options because of this
surrender bill that jeremy corbyn
supported and led the charge on in the
House of Commons what else can we do in
that scenario there's not something we
want but it's a it's become a necessity
if we can't continue with the plan and
and actually the thing that undermines
people's trust in politicians is when
they don't keep their promises what
Boris Johnson wants to do is keep his
promise is to get brexit delivered but
also then to move on and talk about all
the other things that we want to do
with broadband with leveling up schools
funding dealing with gripping social
issues like Social Care so I think he's
sticking to his guns and that's the
right thing to do and I think the voters
appreciate that talking about sticking
to your guns I remember interviewing you
during the election campaign and you
said that the Conservative Party would
be toast if you don't leave by the end
of October if we don't leave by the end
of October will you resign on that basis
I don't think I ever said I was going to
resign what I'm going to do is redouble
our efforts to get a deal but in any
event to leave by the end of October I
think that's the right thing to do of
course if we can't do that and it's very
clear that the blockage is Jeremy Corbyn
the Liberal Democrats and others who are
not willing to respect the referendum
and in the Liberal Democrats case they
say if there's a second referendum and
people voted Lee they wouldn't respect
that either and I think people will say
this this comes down to politicians
keeping their promises and it's about
trust in our democracy I'm doing
everything I can to make sure I keep my
promises and the government of the day
under Boris Johnson delivers could you
still be part of the government that
extends we've Prime Minister's been
absolutely clear on this we're not
extending and I think it's very
dangerous the reality is what are the
problems that we've got what are the
challenges that we've got it will get
easier if we extend it again we just
have more dealer more delay which is one
of the PM's absolute your right to say
he won't countenance it okay and just
finally and my colleague some coats
discovered this week that the Prime
Minister called David Cameron a girly
SWOT and he was overheard a boast
Johnson in pro Minister's Questions also
calling Jeremy Corbyn a big girl's brown
blouse I mean is the word girl an insult
certainly not I'm you know I don't know
about any of those comments I didn't
pick them up but I think the point he's
making about Jeremy Corbyn because he's
been calling for an election for months
if not years and now he doesn't want to
see it through and I think most people
will see that for what it is
so guess what it's a compliment then you
can call me a girlie so at any time